There he is!
Oh...oh...
what's...happening?
It's kicking in.
Here it comes!
(voices echoing) Peyote!
[all moaning]
[shrill scream]
What?
Oh--God!
- Oh...
- Just--we gotta go,
- we gotta go, we gotta go!
Go...
[eerie music]
♪ ♪
What's happening?
[crash]
(both) Oh!
- Oh!
- Oh, my God!
Oh! I'm okay!
(Blake)
Okay, are you
all right?
Oh! Oh, it's a black hole!
- Oh...
- No!
- Oh!
Oh. Oh, God.
Come on!
Wait, no, no, wait--
Oh!
[guys groaning, whimpering]
[Adam, echoing]
It's pretty normal now!
[Ders, distorted]
It's kind of fun!
Oh...
- Oh--
- There he is.
Hey! You can't just
run off like that, okay?
You can get killed
running down that hallway.
I'm just bored--I want us
to all color together!
Uh...
Hey, it's almost lunchtime.
We gotta get out of here now,
man, go somewhere quiet
where we can be alone.
(Ders)
I know just the place
where no one goes...
- the office gym.
- Good call.
We'll put this
little dude on the elliptical,
tucker him out,
and then we'll just wait
for the peyote to wear off.
- Okay.
- Someone make a copy
of my coloring book
so we can all color together.
- Okay, we'll do that. First--
- Hey!
Listen to me!
[sound slowing down]
[voice echoing]
I said I want us
to color together...
now!
- Yeah, whatever you want, man.
- If you want to color,
- we'll color.
- Adam, go make some copies
of the coloring book,
and Blake,
go find some markers
and pens, right?
And since I'm the tallest,
I guess I'll take
the giant to the gym.
Waaahhh!